it is and complete pleasure to be here
and of course an enormous honor to be
here I hope I can handle the technology
which shouldn't be too difficult but you
never know it was very moving to go to
see the gravestone of michael ivanovitch
and Sophia's doctor very simple very
clean very humble nothing says that this
is the gravestone of one of the leading
thinkers of the 20th 21st 22nd 23rd
century anyway I don't want to dwell on
this because otherwise I get so nervous
I can't talk anymore it is a great honor
being here the African cities of
Carthage Utica had Romita m-- and the
other towns were not only large centres
of Commerce but each of them exploited
in an efficient manner the large and
fertile territory which they gradually
occupied olive oil fruit and to a
certain extent wine were the main
products of these cities the African
coast was a vast and beautiful garden
unfortunately however like other gardens
before and after the beautiful gardens
of Africa also contained servants ready
to lure the inhabitants and lead them
astray
thus grasping aristocrats amassed vast
expanses of arable land strangled the
prosperous bourgeoisie of the cities and
impoverished the peasants over time this
led to a revolt that spread from Africa
to the entire empire and was brought to
an end only through the unholy alliance
between a new militarized elite and
imperial strong men who brought the
Empire under control through a system of
Taxation that was
more or less organized rubbery peace was
thus purchased at the expense of liberty
in a manner of speaking everyone became
a slave the great landed proprietors
were slaves of the Emperor but masters
of this colony tenant slaves who lived
on the estates
now caught in hereditary enslavement to
the soil neither they know that children
could ever scape of course the petty
bourgeoisie of the early Empire was
ruined and degraded in other words the
social revolution of the third century
destroyed the foundations of the
economic social and intellectual life of
the ancient world written in the mid 20s
1920s Mikhail Ivanovich was Tufts at
words describing the beginning of Rome's
and continued to haunt the Garden of
Eden
made bountiful and prosperous through
the efficient enterprise of free
citizens the bourgeoisie engaged in
commerce was Roman Africa but also
Russia before their evolution and what
had been so utterly destroyed that it
could not produce anything of
achievement but was Tufts at home his
paradise now irretrievably lost it was
Russia's fate that he sought to
comprehend through the thorough
investigation of the social and economic
conditions without which no attempts to
write a general history of the Roman
Empire can be successful thus Rome's
story became that of man's expulsion
from paradise tall through taxation and
enslavement of peasants to the land and
the evisceration of the free citizens
the Buddhism but Michael was stuffed
have chose to tell the story of Paradise
Lost
through social and economic history may
come as a surprise but accounts of man's
expulsion from Eden are always also
narratives of dystopia and utopia the
causes and consequences of men's fall
from grace a heuristic
tools to analyze present society in
contrast to what might once have been
and might eventually be found again an
ideal city with just obligations fair
taxes and no death
Rostov Serbs social and economic history
of the Roman Empire is thus also A Tale
of Two Cities the cutest arena and the
kavita's day and he was not alone in
using Roman North Africa and the
language of economy and Taxation to talk
about man's expulsion from paradise and
its consequences however while restof
have moved from the description of the
actual enslavement of the later Romans
to a metaphorical fall from grace the
other men who wrote about two cities
Augustine did something into little
different he moved from actual slavery
to the literal expulsion from paradise
which for him was a historical event let
me explain what I mean in 427 or 428
August and Bishop of Hippo Regis in
Norman North Africa wrote a letter to
his friend Alypius Bishop of sagacity
who was then in Rome unroot to Ravenna
where the Roman emperors resided
Augustine wrote to inform Alypius of
recent events he considered so brave
that they warranted imperial
intervention amount of slave traders and
their captors had rounded up men women
and children free Roman citizens to sell
them overseas
as slaves at the time Agustin had been
away only to find upon his return that
members of his church had freed at least
120 of these captives many still lived
in the Episcopal be synced at hippo
forests in these actions and the
consequences calls for a change of
existing law and that was the purpose of
his letter Alypius was the right man to
lobby the imperial court for such a
change
he and Agustin had gone from North
Africa to
Rome and Milan together to practice
forensic rhetoric and Alypius went on to
become Assessor to the court of the
empirical viscus a highly prestigious
leader position since they returned to
North Africa in the three eighties both
men together had successfully lobbied
for several Imperial laws and race
groups hence Augustine's confidence in
Alypius powers to sway the imperial
court at Ravenna was well-placed sending
a letter to the press was however not
Augustine's only action
he wrote a second letter to another
legal expert closer to home a legal
consultant called by stars such
consultants they are usually charged
just before a case was officially
pleaded to examine all the facts at
issue in light of the available
jurisprudence and impure in legislation
use at ladies the legal questions
Agustin presented to that consultant are
the same as those he raised in the
letter to Alypius so that both letters
form a dossier they suggest that Agustin
was preparing at least one probably two
legal cases both as advocate in his own
defense and as a judge in a related case
in short these matters were serious the
letters in question are number ten and
twenty four of the so-called live chat
letters newly discovered in the 1980s
since the discovery led a ten concerning
the slave trade has gone to a
significant amount of scholarly
attention
nearly every recent work on late Roman
North Africa the late Roman economy
slavery in antiquity and late antiquity
the evolution of the law in the later
Roman Empire or an Augusta miss bishop
administrators cites for this letter for
good reason Augustine's description of
the collusion between slave traders
there captures and well situated patrons
in dragging men women and children
across the Roman Empire columns like an
endless River perpetual quasi floovio is
the most detailed account repossess of
the mechanism of the slave trade in the
Empire wires scattered evidence of
papyri inscriptions legal and literary
sources attest to the transport of
slaves bought and kidnapped across the
Empire no other sources as detailed in
describing the organization of that
particular trade this fact alone alerts
us to the importance of this letter two
main reasons account for the positive
information about the ancient slave
trade the first is the utter disdain
with which our elite ancient authors
regarded those who traded in a
merchandise their ravenously consumed
and from which they profited but did not
write about the second is an interesting
collusion in modern historiography
regarding slavery in the late Roman
Empire because that Empire was by 427
and 428 largely governed by Christians
scholars interested in Christian authors
have in general assumed an ameliorating
effect on slavery leading to its
decrease for others beginning with Karl
Marx and Max Weber and continuing with
scholars such as Michael Rostov and
Moses Finley the period signifies the
change from a slave owning society to
its futile successor also characterized
by a degrees in slavery and the rise of
the so-called colonnade the specifics of
that transition are one of the most
central his Geographic debates regarding
the later Roman Empire on its way to
post Roman kingdoms the famous scholarly
positions continue to be contested and
refined as a consequence of these
debates however work on late antique
slavery for its own sake as of recent
vintage we're talking in two thousand
ten eleven twelve thirteen further there
remains a divide between scholars
engaged in the economic social and legal
realities of late Roman slavery and
other forms of bondage that is
historians and those engaged in the
theoretical positions about absolute
divine grace freewill and enslavement to
sin the
theologians let us 10 and 24 fall right
into the middle of this divide and
address every one of the central issues
at stake they reveal that Augustine of
Hippo engaged in the same set of
questions human freedom and bondage at
the same time from a little
administrative economic pastoral and
theological perspective these are truly
remarkable documents and deserve every
citation they get they also deserve to
be read however something that has
happened surprisingly rarely in the
detail required not the only text like
that hence their plenty more
dissertations that can't do it
scholars have discussed letter 10 as a
straightforward description of an
appalling incident the illegal capture
for sale of free Romans that reveals the
Gaston's wish to come to the aid of
those in need but also shows his
judicial role especially his weak
position as administrator powerless
against local heavy weights and the
purported decline of the Roman Empire's
hold on North Africa indeed while these
rivers of slaves flows through hippo
rages the Vandals were moving south
through Spain toward Gibraltar in fact
letter 10 is a combinatorial or
memorandum rather than a letter and this
is an important distinction
while letters were then written for
immediate publication just like Facebook
now a communitarian was strictly private
an exchange between high officials often
addressing difficult and delicate
matters including confidential legal
strategies and tactics in this
memorandum Augustine planned how Alypius
should compel the imperial court to act
down to suggesting official formulations
far from providing a straightforward
account Augustine presented ellipses
with case studies related to the slave
raids selected so that they appealed to
age-old
topics of good versus bad governance
and illustrated his central leader
concerns this central leader concern
contrary to the assumptions of modern
scholars was not the capture and sale of
free Roman citizens but issues those
raids brought into sharp relief the
temporal status of person continued 'no
homonym temporally this seemed personal
status that is the social and legal
status of a person at birth and its
uncertainties often we brought in shock
relief as a consequence of the slave
trade is central to what follows however
since the Gustin went on to have a
fairly significant impact on Western
thought I will conclude by bringing the
theme of personal status briefly into
dialogue with the theological concepts
that occupied Augustine at that very
moment when he wrote letters 10 and 24
for 27 or 28 the Augustinian concepts I
have in mind regard divine grace human
free will and original sin and I will
address them in the context of the slave
trade and issues of uncertain personal
status because Augustine did so himself
for 27 for 28 other dates now except for
these letters rather than the early
amount of for 22 and this relating has
consequences for Augusta meant a slave
trade not yet fully proved at that time
for twenty seven or eight Alypius rather
than traveling to a court in new rel and
had successfully lobbied for legal
action before it wasn't rude to a new
court in trouble in 4:23 a new emperor
had acceded to the throne in the west
valentin in the third in 427 or 428
Valentinian was eight years old a child
who had recently arrived in Ravenna with
his mother Galla Placidia who acted as a
kind of regent in the West earlier in
410 Galla Placidia a daughter of
Theodosius the first had been captured
and enslaved by the Visigoths and Alaric
whose
that roam the vehicles recognized her
value and only released two six years
later in exchange for settlement in
Spain in 427 or 428 Galla Placidia now
as regent was again in a tenuous
position because the two leading
military commanders were locked in a
fatal battle for control of the court in
the real one of them was the military
leader of africa boniface embroiled in
deep struggles with his rival Boniface
thought the military support of the
Vandals who had moved into southern
Spain by 429 the Vandals crossed the
Strait of Gibraltar
when Agustin died in 430 they were at
the gates of hippo ridges however while
Augustine wrote letters 10 and 20 for
the crossing of the Vandals into Africa
was still a year or two in the future
nevertheless they made their presence
felt since their arrival in southern
Spain in 425 they had disrupted the
trade routes linking Africa to
Constantinople and the West
forcing traders to move their wares to
ports for the east such as HIPAA Regis
those wares included slaves whatever the
temps is in turmoil in Ravenna and other
parts of the Roman Empire however in
those years the Roman North African
provinces always prosperous and safe
experienced a veritable boom together
with Egypt and Sicily
North Africa was the breadbasket of the
Empire extensive port facilities of
which hypo Regis was the second-largest
allowed the Roman Imperial Government
the greatest trader to export the
produce from vast Imperial and
aristocracy estates supplies for the
army and the grain olive oil and other
foodstuffs provided by the taxation in
kind of Africa's lands and its
inhabitants by the time of Augustine a
significant portion of the estate's
producing these riches were owned by the
church hipa Regis was the second-largest
episcopal see after Kasich in 411 the
estates Augustine controlled as bishop
were twenty times the size of his
parental estate and in 414 as a result
of his and Alypius successful logging of
the imperial court at Ravenna this size
nearly doubled compared to these days of
the super-rich such holdings were
comparatively modest but they were not
insignificant in some why the Western
Roman Emperor and his or rather her
court at Ravenna felt the precious of
the disintegrating rearm the provinces
of Africa remained the economic engine
of the West in fact the prosperous vast
and beautiful garden the passing of
which Michael Ross doctor had mourned
was alive and well given this context
what caused a gust in such enormous
concern let attend the private
memorandum falls into two parts of which
only the second address the slave raids
and the effect first Agustin thanked
Alypius for sending him the most recent
book of a certain Julian of a claw gnome
to which he was already responding only
then did Agustin delve into the affairs
at hippo and the 120 Roman citizen
captured to be sold overseas in light of
this outrage Augustine instructed
ellipses to get the court to amend a law
already on the books a copy of which he
appended to his letter this law we no
longer possess but it had been addressed
to the governor of Africa and prescribed
trakone e'en punishments for merchants
who sought man capilla slaves overseas a
Gaston wanted the law to be expanded to
punish also merchants who solved free
persons Roman citizens overseas as
slaves this request
makes no sense the kidnapping capture
and sale of free Roman citizens had
always been a crime pluggin were
sufficient leader chronic punishments
firmly in place
no amendment was necessary like mice
it is not clear by the sale of slaves by
traders overseas should be illegal
slaves after all were by definition for
sale hence already these first sentences
should alert us that this
concerns neither the sale of free Roman
citizens nor that of actual slaves those
earlier scholars who noticed the
conundrum explained with Agustin's
lacking comprehension of Roman law
recent scholarship is unanimous in a
testing agustin instead a very high
degree of leader competence but Roman
law is indeed at the root of the
conundrum as Nicholas Purcell has
recently realized societies are deeply
formed by what it is they can sell and
what is excluded from commercial
transactions in the Roman Empire certain
human beings were for sale while others
were in alienable the dividing line was
drawn at birth status at Birth
unalterable by any other means divided
slave and free by law no Freeborn person
could be sought sell himself or his
Freeborn children Freeborn persons were
inalienable forever in this all Roman
legal theorists and all other authors to
the time of Justinian that is to the
sixth century
conquered all other human bodies for
commodities were sale Roman theorists Li
Delin otherwise thus agreed that slavery
was essentially a question of tough luck
a fact of birth quite divorced from the
merit of the human being concerned once
born as a slave one was utterly
dependent on the Masters whim and
whether the master was benevolent or
cruel was independent of a slaves
personal merit though prompt obedience
was always advisable such complete and
utter dependence on another person's
grace had repercussions all agreed that
irrespective of birth the condition of
enslavement even if temporary
for example because of captivity in war
left an indelible mark the macula sera
tutors this stain of slavery was however
not necessarily external hence it is
difficult to distinguish a free man from
a slave difficulty dignity products
ah who are Sabol because it left no
visible maps and this fact became even
more difficult as a consequence of
changes in the social status at birth or
or ego
thus the picture of slavery in the later
Roman Empire is highly complex the clear
positions of the Roman law positing and
preserving the deep divide between
bodies as property and free human beings
was always confronted with a reality in
which this divide was crossed and
re-crossed slaves could be wealthy and
owned slaves of their own Freeborn
persons could be solved and did sell
themselves or could become captives
imperial princesses included further by
the time of Augustine as a consequence
of changes in the tax law under
Diocletian which extended to concepts of
or ago to include the land a great
number of persons lived in a grey zone
in hybrid states as neither true slaves
nor really free among those were the
persons for whom Augustine sought a
change in imperial legislation not least
because incidents such as the slave
raids brought into focus the dire
consequences of such status uncertainty
the traders and their powerful patrons
demanded that Augustine compensate them
for merchandise they considered
illegally seized in numbers that were
not trivial hence it was imperative for
Gaston to clarify what exactly was at
stake kidnapping theft actual sales
something different
Agustin begins with a brief mention of
the free Roman citizens to whom he
returns at the end of his letter
immediately thereafter he states that
among those now freed were very surly
true slaves whose captor was illegal
they pose no problem however because if
not solved by their owners they were
merely object of theft then he mentions
children five or six children who had
been solved by their parents such
transactions were legal however
the traders do not buy these as the
Roman laws allow for work last in 25
years but they buy them precisely as
slaves and sell them overseas as slaves
Oh Sally August and then alerts al
oppose to a woman sought by her husband
even though she had no evident flaws I
was wonder what would have happened had
she had evident force the husband who
was quite well-off was a tenant or
Colonus of our church after that
Augustine returned to the free persons
captured from the rural estates to which
I will return Agustin submitted the same
cases in his second letter to the legal
consultant in some Augustine's let us
focus on persons who fell into the grey
zone in between neither fully free nor
truly enslaved as far as the children
were concerned
Agustin was fully aware that by law
Freeborn children could not be solved
however the sale of their labor for 25
years was permitted this raised
questions of Dominion ownership and
possession that required clarification
who owned what and whose claim took
precedence the protesters of the father
or that of the person who had bought the
labor but not the child Agustin was of
the opinion that he who bought the labor
of such a child had not acquired the
rights inherent in the position of
Domino's or slave owner such rental or
apprenticeship agreements did not
diminish the father's partner potestas
his Freeborn status remained intact
however during the 25-year period during
which the labor was rented out these
children were not free they lived with
Sally as slaves without being very sadly
true slaves were they to be sold
overseas however their status would
change they would be caught illegally in
savage whose perpetual displacement not
sale changed their status as persons not
legally but in fact second the tenant
who sold his wife Augustine's term is
Colonus of the church critical owners of
the church service
or as Augustine asked in letter 24 his
children or was that the prerogative of
the owner of the land to which the
colognes belonged
the answer was entirely open if it was
the right of the owner then in what
capacity as possessor owner of the land
or as Dominus owner of a slave Augustine
was not certain moreover the kiwanis of
letter 10 who sought his wife belonged
to the church who owned the estates of
the church elsewhere Augustine stated
that the owner or Dominus of everything
was God but that Augustine as Bishop was
God's procurator or top managerial slave
who supervised them indeed owned God's
slaves
thus in fact the Dominus in question
with regard to the colognes and his wife
was Agustin with this Augustine returned
again to the Freeborn Roman citizens
whose capture head so enraged him though
he does not say so explicitly when
addressing and appears and recalled that
Augustine was shaping a legal argument
for a court governed by Empress who had
been a slave to herself as a free Roman
citizen
these Freeborn Roman citizens were these
very colonial tenants why technically
Freeborn as a guest and stressed their
status evidently hovered uncertainty
certainly in between they were free but
not entirely though not true slaves
either however these were the men women
and children whose brutally hard labor
fed the Empire they filled the breasts
barktooth parted baskets of Rome and
they did so also on estate owned by the
church as its Colonia thus they were
directly under gustin's control or under
the control of procurator's and others
who controlled them on Augustine's
behalf and as a Gaston makes crystal
clear their legal status was in limbo
this made him vulnerable precisely to
events just as the one now preoccupying
Augustus had they be truly Freeborn the
traders would have committed Plataea
were their slaves their sale overseas
would be prohibited the slaves in
question in the law Augustine appended
were agricultural
slaves monkey Pina origin aria bound for
tax reasons to the land to which they
were born or ego and on which they
produced the revenue so that they could
be sold only with land and certainly not
overseas
hence the draconian punishments for
traders selling such slaves they
participated in tax evasion legal
clarification on the part of the
Emperor's hence crucial and against the
new Libya's had every reason to demand
it indeed an earlier law addressed to
Gaul described Kalani as savvy Terry
slaves of the land but that law to
skirted the issue though free they were
classified in analogy to slaves
something the law categorically
prohibited the legal status of a Colonus
or tenant bound to the land on which he
was born
or originated Colonia origin re in the
late fourth and early fifth century in
relation to that of true slaves bound to
the land is one of the dominant themes
in the historiography of the later Roman
Empire because these persons were in a
position the Roman law was not equipped
to define slavery in Rome dependent on
the clear distinction in Roman law of
property between the in ailable
Freeborn and those who were alienable
because born as slaves this stood in
absolute tension with a reality in which
numerous persons lived in a hybrid state
neither true slaves nor really free many
of the best Roman Minds grabbed it with
this because the consequences were real
among those in limbo were the men women
and children whose labor fed the Roman
Empire and those engaged in the legal
conundrum where the dominie who owned
them and the land to which they were
bound through Origo parentage further
the gradations of unfreedom he addressed
all fled to gradations of freedom which
was not absolute such gradations on
either end of the spectrum affect the
nature of possession and ownership that
is the power of the Father the possessor
and the Dominus if to legitimate powers
have equal yet conflicting claims who
prevails a Dustin's letter ten and
twenty four supported by other
Augustinian writings demonstrate that he
as a bishop acted as judge in cases of
uncertain personal status deliberately
Cousy these cases were reserved for the
highest level of the Roman provincially
judiciary he also acted in defense of
his property which include Cologne II
his and Alypius entreaties to the court
asking for lyrical leadeth clarification
further demonstrate the procedural
character of the late Roman Empire
leader social economic and
administrative changes occurred as a
process in intense negotiation from the
bottom up more often than from the top
down instigated by the practitioners
bishops as estate managers as Domini and
judges were among those practitioners
other process was in domine including
the patrons who sponsored protected and
profited from the activities of the
slave traders in their caches were the
bishops peers as well as members of
their congregations these congregations
Augustine States elsewhere included
slave traders and catchers colony with
their wives and children and true slaves
what are the implications of these two
letters above and beyond that we can
extract by reading them carefully and
more to the point what do they have to
do with Paradise Lost or questions of
earthly and heavenly citizenship first
it is important to keep in mind that
slavery in the Roman Empire and in the
Christian Roman Empire was legal and
that means it was legal for Christians
as well on that basis we began to can
begin to take Augustine on slavery
seriously when Agustin speaks about
slavery in the context of other than
love
ten what did he actually say what was
self understood in a society in which
slavery was leader and a day-to-day
reality as I hope to have shown nothing
in later ten and twenty four regarding
slavery as an earthly social practice
was metaphorical for all the rhetorical
aspects these two letters address social
economic and legal realia with the
exception of the final salvation of this
letter where Gaston reads Alypius as his
con selves all translations render this
as servant does it do justice to
Augustine I think not Augustine greeted
Alypius as his fellow slave spoke of
himself as procreate or managerial slave
of God as Episcopal service say warmed a
bishop and slave of God slave and of God
as Dominus slave owner Augustine in one
letter in this one letter and in nearly
all his writings moves seamlessly
between actual and metaphorical slavery
because these are the metaphor he and
his audience lived by and menu very well
that a slave was not always a true slave
and a Freeborn person was not always
truly free
but heavily constrained through his or
her or ego or origin what then about
Augustine's concurrent thoughts about
grace will and sin that cost so much
outrage amongst some of his
contemporaries to recall a Gaston opened
let attend to Alypius by confirming that
he had received books by a certain
Julian of Atlanta olympus had sent him
and that he was already rebutting julian
the work in question is the incomplete
work against Julian in which Agustin
presented the most mature and recent
account of his position on divine grace
human free will and original sin peccato
originally
though his views on these matters had
evolved over the years in intense
debates with his rivals above all
pillages and Julian of acronym at stake
was the nature of Adam's first sin the
precise reason of his fall and the
implications and consequences for that
sin for the nature of men all agreed
that men much like Adam in Paradise had
been in created free and endowed with a
free will but what happened at the
moment of post-lab Syrian birth this was
a vital question leading Elizabeth Clapp
to observe I doubt that at any time
before or after the first three decades
of the fifth century were a group of
celibate men so concerned with babies
Clark is not certain whether they were
discussing babies in theory of
flesh-and-blood babies but I would argue
that the world of flesh and blood
however at stake I argue was not the act
of birth per se
nachos but it's social leader in
economic aspects and their theological
anthropology illogical and
anthropological implications the
technical term summarizing the social
legal and economic aspects of parentage
is Oracle more to the point the person
who made that decisive shift to focus on
those aspects on Oracle rather than on
natural birth natus had been Augustine
as Julian of a clan had to be seen very
clearly Augustine he says under the
impact of monotheism had substituted or
ago for natus when speaking of man's sin
at birth or ago Tariq home.what defined
the boundary between slave and free in
the Roman Empire status at birth or ago
status at birth not only separated
slaves and free
but determined everyone's little social
and economic status by encapsulating
each person's obligations and privileges
from the nature of citizenship to the
right to marry or ego had always been
essential but it became more so as a
result of diocletian's new taxation
system which led to an increased link
between Origo and tax liability through
birth everyone where the coriolis or
tenant was bound to a particular tax
bracket
thus a colonist was technically born
free but bound by obligations to land on
which he was born
such that he became a slave to that land
sold to the land through Origo at the
same time as my earlier discussion has
shown these little and economic
categories shifted
according to circumstance and experience
or ego though seemingly inflexible was
not in fact utterly fixed one could be
born free yet bound as if one was a
slave so that both freedom and bondage
were linked by a vast grey area in
between
neither freedom nor slavery were thus
absolutes and more importantly there
were not polar opposites in fact as
which we have received them post looser
and post slavery and enlightenment
abolition and enlightenment I think that
Augustine was fully aware of these
complexities of the instability of
notions of freedom and bondage as
implicit in the concept of Oracle status
at birth parentage when he developed his
mature notions of sin through our ago
original sin on a theological level in
other words when making his theological
arguments about sin through our ego I
suggest he was approaching them in a way
that paralleled the problems of freedom
and bondage he encountered with actual
status evident in these two letters
reflecting a complex interplay of birth
status bad luck what a Gaston explored
geologically in his work against Julian
as well in his de batata de completed in
file 426 was the same modified peril
essence of Oracle freedom and bondage in
human nature like the majority of his
contemporary classical leaders Augustine
too had initially been of the opinion
that man was created free and born free
from sin but then accumulated sinned
through the remainder of his life
concurrent with his return to Africa and
the beginning of his Episcopal Augustine
views began to change prompted by a
public debate with a highly educated man
keen Christian leader over the
interpretation of Paul's letter to the
Romans Agustin began to reconsider
slowly but surely his ideas about the
nature of men his dependence on God
obedience and the freedom of the will
his earlier play to install inspired
confidence in man's rationality and
self-reliance his innate freedom
increasingly gave way to the notion that
man was born with a free will but
through birth or ego bound to sin he
posited a notion of men as powerless and
utterly dependent on the arbitrary grace
of an omnipotent divine master or
Dominus whose grace operated entirely
without regard to man's individual merit
Augustine no longer held that man was
born free and only subsequently enslaved
to a sinful body as most of his
contemporaries thought thought and as he
had once thought himself but insisted
that men though endowed with freewill
was bound to sin through his or ego
obligations he had inherited from Adam's
first act of disobedience
the peccato origin Allah after all from
whom
where would where would Christ have
repurchased us if he had not been sold
to sin through Oracle
augusten to insisted upon the redemptive
nature of divine grace but I survived
but as I have shown whether one was born
enslaved and dependent utterly on the
mysterious operation of a divine grace
or received such grace as a result of
the merit of one's inborn free will as
Augustine's opponents such as Palacios a
julienne thought made a real difference
in a world that held born free and born
slaved absolutely and commensurable a
world in which our ego was simple at the
outset Augustine's have used change
because a challenge by the mannequin
fortune Nasus prompted him to read
Paul's letters in a new way for fortune
artist Paul's declaration in Romans that
men's soul is captive to the law of sin
that is in his mortal limbs meant that
though the human's solid will are linked
to God and the good they are constantly
taken captive and enslaved by no
pressing materially existing evil for a
manichaean interpretation based on the
opposition of two nearly equally
powerful masters the enslavement of
man's soul from his birth into coercive
physical servitude that the soul which
is with with its will constantly
resisted was part of an epic battle of
good versus evil
that has positively connoted for Gaston
who had to fend one God and sent both
that God's goodness and His omnipotence
the challenge was much greater
especially if he took the existence of
evil seriously and that he did
thus Agustin began to argue that man was
through birth or ego enslaved to sin
however response before that enslavement
was not the body not the nature of the
body as the opposing other but rather
the soul itself through the collective
legacy of Adam's fall the body was
enslaved to the soul but the soul when
it sinned enslaved itself sin was the
disobedience of the soul and the will
against its own nature and its own
Commandments thus all human beings
though free in their will were also born
slave to sin in their very own will
neither a true slave nor entirely free
hence the soul could be saved only if it
voluntarily submitted to obedience to
God only the act of will
leading to surrender truly freed for
that to occur however divine grace was
necessary and such grace God granted
arbitrarily as a Dominus could and
should individual merit had little to do
with it phrased differently for
augustine heritage or ego in the
theological sense is as mixed and
complex as it is in the social sense
because man and men's will is absolutely
born free in the image of God yet
enslaved through the inherited sin of
Adam as in the new Roman laws concerning
Colonia origin REE both are true at the
same time one can be free and bound at
the same time even though that is
confusing and indeed in conflict with
strict interpretations of the law
Paul also had made that point the good I
want to do I cannot do the
contradictions and complexities of that
observation became even more pressing I
think to a man such a Gaston was
increasingly confronted by the muddled
middle ground of social and economic
realities also reflected in the Roman
law of Oregon ever more muddled as a
result of diocletian's tax laws these
realities created a conceptual for space
for Agustin to rethink the philosophical
arguments about freedom and bondage in
relation to his actual experiences as a
theologian and Bishop where human
self-determination was far more complex
and frail than earlier and contemporary
defenders of Christian self determinism
wished to acknowledge and hence explore
aghast never denied that man was formed
free regardless of his opponents claims
but he held that this freedom was
compromised because men had been sold
through his or ego itself compromised by
the sin of Adam to sin freedom was
relative and no longer guaranteed by
Auriga alone but relayed on reliant on
the grace of a Dominus who might restore
what was lost in in slave
bison I certainly do not want to offer
more no causal explanations for
Agustin's notions of divine will grace
and original sin I have to sketch in the
briefest possible fashion rather I want
to suggest that a gas been refined and
elaborated these concepts over and
against competing ideas now associated
with the name collages and jr. of
Oakland on not only as theoretical
concepts I think that a gust in the
bishop a state manager advocate just
pastor member of the late Roman elites
intensely engaged with the different
realities of freedom independence in
Roman North Africa office in his
theological concepts of sinned through
or ego will embrace his reflections of
these realities
if so then agustín's engagement with
this world the Cuba test arena of the
Roman Empire was more direct than has
been argued because like Michael Rose
Tufts if so many centuries later
Augustine who used the language of
social status taxation and the economy
to describe and analyze the kavita's in
which he then lived Roman North Africa
to formulate ways in which we might
rejoin the ideal city from which we all
have been expelled the kavita's day
thank you very much